[Music]
[Applause]
Charles Barkley joining us Charles good
morning how are you first of all the SOS
band didn't sound like that that thing I
just heard
damn your favorite 80s band do you have
one well my favorite band all time is a
rap group called Public Enemy uh that's
my favorite rap group band and arita
Franklin's my favorite singer after that
so that's that's you know Dan I'm old
man you know I I love that music from
that was my day my hey day yeah but
those are different artists there if you
go to a public enemy concert or you go
to Rea Franklin uh you're probably
having different people uh your audience
different yeah that's 100% but it was
something something about Public Enemy
that always hit me in my soul if you ask
listen to their words uh they were way
ahead of their time uh and I I just love
those guys you remember your first
concert I think my first concert was
Phil
Collins okay I I I I I think our coach
when I was playing at Auburn he took us
I think we were playing
Kentucky and he took us to see Phil
Collins and I didn't know anything about
Phil Collins you know it's kind of like
the you know the Eagles are my favorite
band I've been traveling with the Eagles
for the last 30 years getting ready to
go see them actually on their last two
like November the 3D I think they're
they're in Atlanta I've seen them 50
times I've been with those guys even
before Glenn Fry passed away but they're
the kind of band like Billy Joel or Phil
Collins you don't even know all the good
songs they sing until they start singing
them because like I say we didn't even
want to go see Phil Collins and then
when he started singing songs I'm like
oh he sings that oh he sings that it's
the same way when I started going to see
the Eagles about probably 35 years ago I
go to the Eagles probably five to seven
times a year yeah um I know you're going
to the Auburn game how how close do you
think you got to convincing Auburn to
bring in Deion Sanders to be your
coach that's a great question I made it
publicly and
privately uh known that I wanted
Dion uh that's all I could do uh I
really wanted Deon at Auburn because I
think wherever he goes he's going to be
successful he's just that great of coach
and a
person and uh but you know what I have
to be careful with that Dan we hired H
freeze and I'm all in on Coach freeze
but I really want Deon and Auburn but
like I say we got coach freeze now and I
got to support him 100
per. what how do you uh I guess sum up
what has happened at Colorado this year
with Dion how would you describe it it's
it's uh what I know that Dion was going
to do like he has the it Factor like
first of all he's a really great person
you know I think sometime we
see people their Persona and don't
understand listen to him but I tell you
man he's a great coach he got a great
staff he reminds me a lot of Nick Sabin
and I think Nick sabin's the greatest
coach ever he's not a afraid to hire
great assistance you look at Dion staff
I think everybody on his staff either
played or Co been a head coach somewhere
and see I think what separates Sabin a
lot of coaches are cowards Dan they they
afraid to hire good coaches because they
worry about their job if you're secure
in your coaching you hire good
assistants because you can't do
everything you can't do everything you
can't run the special teams coach to
offense coose to defense clach to
linebackers coach to offens line you
have to hire good assistants and I think
that's what Nick saens does better than
anybody else and when you look at Dion
staff everybody's been a head coach in
college or the NFL and that's why he's
gonna be successful when you were at
Auburn so Frank Thomas was at Auburn Bo
Jackson at Auburn were were you guys
there at the same time yes we were there
all all about three years to college I
was with those guys and me and and me
and me and me and Frank got treated like
crap just for the record I want to make
that perfectly clear because Auburn as
much as I love Auburn they don't until
Bruce Pearl got there and sunny Smith
they never cared about
basketball like you know I used to go
out people would knock me out the way to
get to Bo Jackson I you know you know
but you know I I it didn't bother me at
the time it bothered me later like even
when I go back down there now if I'm
with Bo they're gonna knock me out the
way to get to Bo
Jackson you know but football just King
Kong down there I mean that's just how
it is but that that's the South though
Dan you know how the south is Alabama
Georgia Florida I mean uh football just
King did you realize what you were
seeing with Bo Jackson oh yeah oh yeah I
saw Bo play at high school we had a
really good high school team and one
Friday night we went and played both and
the one thing that people don't
understand about both you know like most
guys get bigger and stronger as they
grow and get to high school get to
College both the same size his whole
life and we played
them and I'm not even exaggerating Dan
every time he touched the ball he either
scored or came close to scoring he was
so big so strong so fast and I tell
people one of the great Geor geys of my
life was getting to go watch Bo Jackson
play football every weekend but you
didn't play football I played one day
then I realized I
was I realized they were hidden out
there hey you know it's it's only two
sports where you can't be you can't you
can't Fake It Boxing and football if you
step on a football field or in a boxing
ring bad stuff can happen to you you can
fake basketball I mean we got some guys
out there s for than baby baby crap but
you can't fake football and you can't
fake boxing I played one day Dan and
then it was bad coaching too because he
put me on the defensive line I just ran
full speed into a dude for two hours I
had no idea what what what we were doing
and like seriously he came to me later
he says I should have put you at tight
end or or linebacker or something like
that but he put me on the defensive line
because those really the only two spots
the offensive line and the defensive
line those actually the only two spots
on a football team that actually work
all the time but if you were going to
put together a football lineup from
basketball
players well please don't say LeBron
this to be making me so mad thinking he
can play
football yeah he he he he played
football in high school cuz he was
bigger than everybody else what's one
thing about the pros you're not bigger
or faster than anybody else I will tell
you something though I think my guards
like 62 63 they would make uh like a a
Russell Westbrook somebody like that
guys like that built sturdy yeah I think
they would make great wide receiver or
safeties well I could see Russell
Westbrook as a a strong safety a defense
no question you know I love that guy as
a player and he could he if he had
played football he would have been all
pro as a safety or a corner yeah but I
think most of the guards who were fast
and quick like a Kevin Johnson you know
I think uh you know guys like that I
think they could have been a wide
receiver or a safety or a corner but
let's be honest most of my NFA NBA
players they're not tough enough to play
football
they're not no disrespect to him we now
we have way more Talent now don't get me
wrong but as for as that going out there
just knocking the hell out somebody
every play basketball players aren't
built like that talking to Charles
Barkley the Hall of Famer your reaction
when you heard the Bucks were getting
Dame Lillard was
what well I think that made them the
favorite in the Eastern Conference you
know I to be honest with you Dan I
thought that was a good trade for all
three teams uh I thought it was a good
trade for all three teams but the big
winner what a Milwaukee bucks and uh you
know it's g i and I hope it keeps
Giannis in Milwaukee his entire career
and I pull for Dame to win the
championship I pull for guys who haven't
won the championship to win the
championship because the one thing you
don't want to be you don't want to be on
the crap list uh when you guys say great
great player but he never won anything
and you know I'm on that list you know
me Carl and Patrick and those guys who
are all Great Hall of Fame players but
it sucks when people try to min minim
minimalize minim iiz your achievements
so I really hope Dame can get him a
championship in Milwaukee but I hope the
main thing it keeps Janis in Milwaukee's
entire career yeah I I think what the
Suns did is kind of sneaky they need a
depth there uh what what concerns you
about the
Suns nothing they got everything they
need uh but I will team to beat out
west during the conversation I love what
the Lakers did this summer I L what the
Lakers did and also you can't disrespect
the Nuggets I think they lost a couple
key pieces that's the only thing
concerns me about the Nuggets but you
got to really love what the lers have
done and the sons have done but those
three
teams uh don't forget Sacramento now
Sacramento should have beat the Warriors
but in the East it's the Celtics and the
and and the uh bucks they're they're
their head and shoulders above everybody
in the East how frustrating is it when
you face somebody like the jok
and he doesn't do anything special but
he's you look at the stat sheet you go
oh my God like he had that I mean he's
not fast he can't jump but he
understands the game would you rather
face a guy who had incredible
athleticism or the guy you're going this
drives me crazy because he doesn't do
one thing better than me well I I I what
he reminds me of labry bird and Magic
Johnson uh because neither one of those
guys you would say had exceptional
athletic ability but they are two of the
greatest players ever because of hard
work and brains and work ethic and uh
and I've told people they're the two
most important people in NBA history
because they saved the NBA every time I
see magic and bird I said thank you for
making all us you know they save the NBA
went for those two guys I mean obviously
Michael took it to another level but if
it was for magic and bird none of us
would be around today but he reminds me
of magic and bird they didn't have have
exceptional athletic ability but they're
two of the greatest ever and to answer
your question I always want to play
against really athletic guys because
most of them were dominant rocks first
and
foremost and because they because they
always played the game on athletic
ability they never used their brains
yeah and it gotta and the thing is you
can get their athletic ability in high
school you can get your athletic ability
in college but the problem is when you
get to the NBA you're not going to be
more talented and run or Michael or
Kevin Durant or Devin Booker or Jason
Tatum that's the problem so I used to
love playing against Athletic guys
because you can outsmart them because
they just want to run and jump they
don't use any of their brain cell I used
to tell people I used to hate Jeff
Turner at Vanderbilt I used to hate him
they box you out every play I like yo
man can we just run and jump and get the
rebound I don't want to wrestle with you
then when you play against a Kentucky or
Florida
it became an athletic contest then you
can really do your thing I used to hate
to play with them them guys who box you
out every play every time I saw valer
like damn they gon they gonna block me
out every play they're gonna they're not
g they're not gonna be careless with the
ball they gonna make those simple little
basic passes I mean I used to hate
playing against the smart kids Dan I
really did how uh how you doing gambling
with the NFL I'm doing good the Lions
man hey I've been on the Lions for like
the last I started on the line you know
you Dan you got to in me to Dan Campbell
I'm the biggest Dan Campbell fan in the
world I've been on his bandwagon for
like over a year now I started betting
on the lines like the last six seven
games last year I had them against
Kansas City they screwed me against the
Saints but they made up for it last week
and last night but I really I'm a big
man I love Dan Campbell he just seems to
me anybody who loves this sport I got
love and respect for them and and you
know I so I had the them last night uh
oh and let me tell you something man I'm
on drive to New York and beat the hell
out of whoever stopped that damn uh
Marlins game last night I had the
Marlins last
night they had a three-hour rain delay
and screwed me out of my money Dan and
say they're not gonna play the game
unless it's necessary next Tuesday I was
like I cannot believe they I I I was
like I'm going take the Marlins they've
lost two or three in a row they're going
to win going into the weekend and I'm
sitting there I'm going back and forth
it's two to one and then there's a rain
delay and then three hours later there's
a rain delay and don't normally they
call the game if after five innings and
award somebody a
win are you going to Vegas for the Super
Bowl you know I got to make that
decision it's so interesting you asked
that question you know me and my boys I
got about 10 15 guys we've been 26
straight years to Vegas for the Super
Bowl but we know it's going to be
ridiculous and stupid and crazy so we're
trying to decide to be honest with you
we we're gonna we got time before we wor
we've been 26 straight years Vegas is
the best place in the world for the
Super Bowl and we're like yo because the
last time I went there for a big event
was the NBA allar game and it was one of
the worst experiences of my life it took
like two hours to go like two blocks
you know everybody's there all the Riff
ref drove in from around the country I
told him I guys why don't we all just
come to my house we can because we play
golf all weekend like we play golf even
on the Sunday of the Super Bowl so we
play golf all day Friday all day
Saturday and we play Sunday morning
because the game don't start at 3
o'clock Pacific so I told the guys I
said we got to make a decision either
all y'all come and stay at my crib or we
go there and be it but the problem is
you won't be able to get around it
probably going to be hard to go play
golf on Friday and Saturday and Sunday
yeah uh you know my favorite parts of
the subway commercials are when they
give you a short amount of time to get
all those words in and you're you're
doing your damnedest to tread water to
get all those words in describing the
sandwich Dan let me tell you something
what's crazy number one I have really
enjoyed working with Subway it's been
amazing and fun and amazing all this all
the people they put in the commercial
when we first started doing the
commercial I thought it was the
stupidest thing in the world I really
did so you know I go in this little room
and I'm talking like hey Dan Patrick
it's good to see you blah blah blah hey
how the other guys doing they're like no
you gotta go faster I said hey Dan
Patrick how you doing how the other guys
doing they're like no you gotta go
faster I was like nobody talks like that
and they and they're yelling at me in in
because we we I'm on in on the zoom with
like 20 people they're like no you got
to go faster Chuck and I says when I
walked out the first I'm not this the
true story Dan the first time I did the
commercial I called my agent I said man
this the stupidest thing I've ever done
in my life but I got to admit when they
put it together yeah it works perfectly
but when I first did the commercial I
told my AG I said he I'm glad I cast
that check already because this gonna be
the worst commercial ever but but well I
give I give him credit it's been a great
relationship but man you're right and
I'm screaming too Dan I'm talking as
fast as hum possible I mean I'm talking
really fast and I'm screaming and you're
right it's it's it's it's fun when I do
it but I'm screaming into a microphone
for like two hours as fast as I can talk
I actually have to shut up for the rest
of the day because I lose my
voice safe travels to Auburn great to
talk to you again thank you bud all
right man I appreciate it hey you guys
be safe have a great weekend War Dam
Eagle that is Charles Barkley wa